All right.
A church family. This is, uh, my good friend Cliff Dalton.
Cliff, uh, grew up in a church that, uh,
practiced infant baptism, uh,
and as one, he was baptized as an infant.
He came to saving faith as a teenager,
and about three years ago, he started coming to Henderson.
And after, uh, searching the scriptures
and talking with pastors
and thoughtful prayer, he thought, you know what?
I should follow the Lord in believers' baptism.
And so today, based on your testimony, my dear brother,
cliff, I baptize you in the name of the Father
and the Son and the Holy Spirit.
Amen. Amen.
Thank you so much, church, family. Let's please pray.
Heavenly Father, our, our cups are full from today.
We thank you so much for all that you're
doing, all that you've done.
We thank you for your unbelievable gift of salvation,
that this is a picture of, this is not it,
but it's such a, a powerful symbol
and a powerful manifestation of the death
that you have brought to life.
We thank you for what you have done in cliff's life
and heart, and what you're going to keep doing in Him
and all of these, uh, recipients of your salvation.
Lord, we ask for more.
Lord, we, we thank you so much for what you're doing.
Father, we ask that you would continue
to fall on this church.
You continue to move in our hearts.
We thank you for the sermon today.
May we never forget, we, we don't need to leave here
and just say, well, that was really great,
and then forget you, Lord.
We want to commune with you all throughout the day.
And so we ask for your blessing from here
in Jesus' name, amen.
But your.